[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feels like I've been walking up to the
sky
[Music]
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Wednesday it's
hump day don't forget to hump someone
you love today director yet but I feel
like you forgot last week honestly no
when you live with CEO you never forget
that a tight day Oh cute how is he he's
good you know he's really top of mind
for me because I did a podcast yesterday
with my vet who was his podcast called
we don't deserve dogs and it was
literally just one hour talking about
Theo and normally like talking about
anything but myself is incredibly boring
but the joy and pride that I feel for
Theo it was actually more satisfying to
talk about Theo than it was to talk
about me and I guess that's what that
having a kid is like it was an extension
of you and like because you can birch to
him he is a part of you and so it's
really like you're talking about
yourself and my dad has known feel like
since he was born and she has the utmost
like she gets it like she gets she's a
part of PGM nation feel like competitive
with him because they're both doctors
no no it's two totally different Theo is
a doctor without border at least it does
have borders Oh
totally different careers very
interesting and you know doctors also do
need doctors so dis is Theo her
internist while she is his vet yes very
interesting yeah lines of dr. hood are
so I'm feeling good also eighty so
beautiful out today so I'm the studio is
looking fly yeah I've never been someone
who's like so affected by the weather it
really like dictates how the show is
gonna go and what its gonna look like so
I'm just so grateful from blue skies I'm
very much an endorsee person and I've
never really felt like the weather was
you know personally affecting me but
here I am just like being the weather
girl yeah we could be about that we
could have a weather segment well Ben
wanted when Ben came to the studio for
the first time he obviously like just
like he's very similar to me he finds a
way to make everything about him and he
decided that he wanted to be our
weatherman and he wanted we have a
little balcony and he wanted to stand on
the balcony and do the weather and I
said no one would want that I think that
now that you said it everyone would want
that really yeah but he would have to
come in early to film it he would be
like the crazy weatherman for the
morning because what is weather Cox yeah
and if at this point you still haven't
seen morning Morning Glory like make
sure to turn this off right now go watch
and come back yeah honestly I would say
Morning Glory is the only content more
premium than the show the best movie
ever made it really is big it doesn't go
live every day Monday through Friday at
10:30 a.m. Eastern Time therefore like
that's their cross to bear yeah but we
are just serving up fresh content every
day and I just want to say it when I
like jinx our show but I'm feeling
20:20 much like the news of 20/20 has
been out of this world like I'm feeling
like our 20/20 shows have been funnier
than ever by the way 1000% except I was
more surprising more people like the
toasters are on to everything in
yesterday's show I was not feeling about
the whole time I got almost vomited the
entire show no I'm not pregnant just
that and I'm surprised nobody said
anything yesterday I really felt like
was my worst show of the year
Oh interesting well I feel they song as
one of us is good I think we're good and
as long as we like one key moment and
the key moment was talking about
Victoria pretending that she was shy
when she's also the girl who came out of
The Bachelor MO and said that her [ __ ]
was wet right exactly and just like
don't get you a girl who couldn't do
both of those things because they're a
contradiction to one another so thanks
for not calling me out on that but I'm
back I'm not feeling nauseous today so
better than ever we're so glad to hear
that you have a great show for each day
we have some good stories this is the
first day in like six days that we're
not talking about mex it but I just
talked about mexic yeah also I saw a
picture of her she was spotted in Canada
getting onto a seaplane it was it said
Whistler air on the side so I wonder
where she was going she was wearing a
sweater from the row and a khaki green
jacket and brown boots honestly not a
cute look really not cute that sounds
adorable
it wasn't it was just like it was so
like basic waspy outfit well she's like
being watched so closely right now that
she actually can't trust too cute right
now or else people will say like where
the funds coming from where the fat was
you can accept like the road that's a
little crazy um
she could've at least gone with
Elizabeth and James or like hmm your
comment or now welcome but also then
people would have been like oh she's
already like the red carpet star etc so
I'm sure like her whole look is planned
by a team of experts that's crazy
my luck good this morning was actually
planned by team of s F skirt escorts
experts and me and my multiple
personalities we picked out this outfit
and we're really excited about it except
it's an interesting day because it's
like nice out and I wouldn't say that
I'm wearing capris I would say I'm
wearing a jean that shows a little bit
of my ankle no you're wearing a jean
that's meant to be a Capri on a tall
girl and for you it's the right length
yes I would say about three inches of my
ankle is showing which is so cute except
for the fact that my leg there is also
yep I'm seeing it that's it you know
it's like winter but not it's like a
warm winter day because my ankles are
showing but so is my leg hair and you
know what I meant to ask you about this
off air but now that um we're on the air
I might as well ask you know I'm go to
Mexico this weekend yeah my annual trip
with - Paltrow and I'm singing about
getting a leg wax don't do it oh really
because you're also getting is
right Anning you can't get a wax too
close to a tan or else like the skin is
still raw and it doesn't pick up the tan
oh damn okay and also like a leg wax if
you started to wax your legs like more
regularly in like the next two or three
times you'd be in a good place but the
first time because your hairs grow all
the different ways it will do nothing
and you'll have hairy non tanned legs
okay I just feel like there needs to be
some sort of medium between shaving your
legs and waxing your legs because
shaving your legs is like cool but the
next day it's all back like it's not an
effective method for like a four day
trip I've never done there but I don't
know I feel like there's some merit to
it I'm like talk about all the different
options so that toasters can like write
in their horror stories I'm using there
you know oh so um I was trying to do
lasering I was lasering my armpits with
snitch and I had to stop because my hair
wasn't my hair's too light and wasn't
picking up on the laser and they were
like growing the place is really great
and watching something she what I was
like about lasering was amazing we were
doing at Romeo and Juliet laser but it
just wasn't working for me and I was
just like not waxing because I was lazy
and I'm really sad about it but I guess
that's like the con to having light hair
so I I lasered my armpit so years ago at
Romeo and Juliet it was the best thing I
ever did
I'm like so jelly I get three little
strands of hair in my armpit see here
and I can live with that I'm really so
jealous but at least like my hair is
light so I don't have to right shake it
every single time you see it ya know
you know that's just but it's
interesting that people with light hair
can't get laser oh can we recap Kristen
Dodie yesterday I want to talk what you
thought about her I'm so like actually
last night's episode didn't conflict me
too much because I felt like we were
getting some answers and I actually do
think as two people who were arguing
about her last week I got some answers
in the sense of I kind of understand the
path that she's on this season where
it's like eight her lease isn't up for a
while and so he's not gonna move out
it's like a gist achill I and I
understand that like especially when you
know you are living with someone and
lisas really do get in the way of
relationships even when it comes to
moving in with someone you have to like
revolve it around Elise so what she was
saying was like we're broken up and
we're gonna move out from each other
when my lease is up and if that proves
to be true in the show right then if he
never sets foot into the new house then
she was just getting bogged down by
logistics yes she ain't you
biding her time and like okay if she's
living with this guy because you know
they can't move out for a while like
okay you have sex with him like you know
what I mean right he's there yeah you
know him like it's it's it's not so
crazy so Coco and I also feel like on
the show they really like she really
comes off so crazy sometimes and so
emotional but then like when we were
with her like she was just so cool and I
feel like when we only see that crazy
emotional side of her it's like how can
you have a friend who's like that 24/7
yeah but she's not least yesterday we
saw the side of her that's like oh I
understand why everyone is your friend
yes she's like funny and cool and at the
wedding like it was super fun to be at
the wedding but Ben was literally the
only person I knew like hardcore and
Stephen McGee like and I was latching on
to people that I know it was like being
in the social setting like where you
don't know a lot of people and it's also
televised it's kind of scary and out of
all the people there she was literally
so nice to me like holding my hand
taking me actually we're going here
we're going there when like I've only
met her a few times she was so nice to
me for seemingly no reason she's just a
really nice girl and they think that's
why I like went to bat for her last week
because when you see someone on TV you
don't really know everything about them
and I think what the toasters got from
her interview yesterday was like wow
she's kind of calm yeah and not really
what she seems so there's more to it
than what you see on TV yes I agree but
when they only show like those crazy
sizes I understand are the most
interesting it makes me feel like oh if
I had a friend who was like that all the
time I couldn't be their friend
no so but then when she's sitting here
saying stassi's on her granny more like
why would she be friends with you no
that's devastating really to hear that
now even in real-time off-camera like
the witch's a we know are very much not
a thing and that she doesn't know if
she's gonna be invited to the wedding
even though she said up Stassi and Beau
I think that is so wild yeah I know like
what's an invite no I know it's it's
nothing and especially now that she's
totally moved down from Carter she's
like well no right what's the problem
now and for her to say that she's gonna
find out with us on TV like what they're
saying behind her back
could you imagine who's giving me Tamra
and Vicki Lee dives yesterday more show
with us you have no idea what you and
Kelly were never The Witches of Lee ho
no not even close
ten years of French you're not even
close could sleep with your friend's
boyfriend and we'll still make up so
what could be worse than that
totally I don't know we're gonna recap
the entire episode of bed a pump rules I
watched siesta key so there's a lot
we're gonna recap and we have dere
toasters that'll be at the end of the
show but before that I don't have a
watch but I think I think it's time I
think it's time there's not like a clock
or anything but I'm just like my duty my
biological clock is telling me that
okay that it's time for the past five
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast and that's true you know I
don't want to step on anyone's toes and
like say it's not time and we already
said it's time and there's so much to do
and so much to discuss but I would be
remiss I would be I would be devastated
honestly I might even be heartbroken if
I didn't let everyone know that today's
episode is brought to you by noon
getting in shape doesn't have to be
about losing a specific amount of weight
or a magic number on the scale
it's about healthier habits and feeling
better about yourself if fitting into
that favorite pair of jeans is your goal
then great but there are many reasons
you might want to practice self-care and
every person is different and because
we're all different
NUMA just to your lifestyle they teach
you the psychology behind the decisions
you make and help you to keep track of
everything from workouts and steps to
analyzing your diet and recommending
healthy recipes new muscle connects you
with a personally assigned goal
specialist and a community of other
número make on numerous like the
toasters so you have all the support you
need to empower you to change it's easy
and convenient they have an app it's a
habit changing solution that helps users
learn to develop a new relationship with
food through personalized courses it's
based in psychology they teach you why
you do the things you do and empowers
you with the tools that you need to
break bad habits and replace them with
better ones no food is considered good
batter off limits on noon they teach you
moderation and can be used in
conjunction with many preexisting
popular diets if you want they don't
they don't tell you what to do and what
not to do they basically just teach you
to take an inside look in your own mind
and make better decisions for yourself
you're human if you go off track there's
no shaming just tips to help you get
back on track tomorrow
tons of toasters have used Noom we use
it and we've heard that you guys are
loving it and that makes us so happy so
we even offer for you guys and you don't
have to change it all in one day
small steps make big progress sign up
for your trial today at noon and oom
dot-com slash toast what do you have to
lose visit Noom comm slash toast to
start your trial today that's n oom
dot-com / toasts sign on feel amazing ok
are you ready for our first story and
it's of course your news that toasters
me first but there is an addendum to
this story that hasn't been reported to
get that I'm so excited to share with
all of you totally their exciting very
exciting first up Vanessa Hudgens in
Austin Butler breakup after nearly nine
years together and comes as a shock to
the nation unless you're toast unless
you're a toaster because someone shared
in the toasters earlier this week that
Vanessa Hudgens an awesome butt
we're about to announce their breakup
she was supposed to do some sort of
interview and had to cancel because they
broke up and so therefore the news is
out I just want to like discuss this for
one second because I do think it is so
so sad I think it's tragic I think that
their relationship was just so cool for
so many reasons like one they were
together for so long
there were highs and lows of Fame like
he's like becoming a really big star now
he just got cast as Elvis Presley he was
in one spouting time in Hollywood and
he's always she's always been like the
star like now his stars rising and I
just thought it was really cool that
like through like the treacherous nosov
Hollywood they always stayed together
and I thought I think that she's such a
cool girl like she's like super famous
but like not really relevant you know
what I mean she has 37 million Instagram
followers Blake doesn't really work no
but she's so relevant like she's like a
style icon so many people she's a
Coachella icon and then every time she
does work or put herself in a film other
than like night before Christmas like
when she was in rent everyone is so
taken with her talent when she was in
Greece the performance of a lifetime she
is so talented but also she's just an it
girl yes definitely for her to be with
um is this Jake Ryan no no no he was
he's a he's from I want to see Zoey 101
that's where he got it hold on he was on
Hannah Montana I know it we always have
this conversation he wasn't on Hannah
Montana he was a Nickelodeon kid I I'm
almost a hundred percent sure he was on
zoey 101 you're right yeah no he was
like chases big competition and of
course phones in the Carrie Diaries
right so that's where this really gets
personal for me because if you know
anything about me you know that I'm such
a big fan of the Carrie Diaries like a
show that came and went far too quickly
me and Mark are obsessed with it and he
plays Carrie Bradshaw's high school love
interest and he's like such a cutie and
that carries like such a nerd but he
like sees the good in Carrie and just
like really doesn't go with Donna
LaDonna the popular girl he goes to
Carrie even though she's like a freak um
and that show got canceled way too soon
and I do think that awesome Butler's
career could have been different if
everybody's seen the potential in Carrie
Brown show but his career is like where
it needs to be right now
he's like the epitome of young Hollywood
and I know that everyone's saying it's
like now that he's getting big like the
relationship doesn't work and I just
don't think it's that I can't I can't
believe that that's the reason I refuse
to believe that that's the reason but it
appears to be because he got the role of
Elvis probably Presley that like
everyone was dying for like I heard
Harry Styles tried out for an Ansel
Elgort and
Butler who's like relatively unknown
before it was just before but he does
look like out of this though no and by
that he's blonde but he dyed his hair
black and now but during the casting
process he dyed it black and now it was
like he did it on purpose because he
looks so much like Elvis Presley that is
so crazy
I don't think it's it's that he's
getting big and now he's like leaving
her in the dust I feel like for a long
time there was always like it was always
so crazy that they were still together
you know it didn't really make any sense
no but the fact that it didn't make
sense made sense
exactly but so now I just feel as though
it's time for Vanessa and Zac Ephron to
reunite because no listen hear me out
back in the day trying Gabriela like
they were it and I understand people
change but now the people that they've
evolved into like where Zac Efron is now
with his bleached blond hair very artsy
and Vanessa Hudgens at Coachella like I
feel like these two people should be
together they're more similar than ever
but I honestly feel as though that might
have been like a really toxic time in
there both of their lives like you know
what they say about the Disney culture
like I just think that it's better to
move on um Vanessa and Hudgens and I
know she dropped the N but I refused to
drop it she's just at a different place
in her life um I don't like does she
have any money I was wondering about
things like that she doesn't really work
but she's 37 million followers on
Instagram like that could pay you can
live in a mansion in LA yeah own it with
37 million followers yeah she posts an
ad here and there she's definitely like
the face of some campaigns I think she's
more than that
she's like a bee or a girl yeah it works
probably when she wants to when she
needs to and she does the Netflix she
does the princess switch oh right you
know that was just like a crowd favorite
yeah I'm telling you like now I mean I
guess my first ship of the day that I'm
sailing out to sea from my mini port
that I've purchased is janessa its
senescent but then you told me an update
in the story that's even crazier okay so
then the toasters were sharing so if you
just want some inside scoop that Austin
Butler checked into a hotel with a girl
they are sharing a room it has one
bedroom one king bed one room one king
bed and she left she said she would let
us know when she figured out who the
girl was and the girl is Olivia de ganj
who plays el in the society girl who
accidentally makes the poison pie it was
so good
and
looked her up and she is playing the
role of Priscilla Presley in the new
Elvis Presley film so it makes sense why
they would be together you know we call
that ladies the whole circle moment yeah
it's just like it all checks out I'm
gonna go with that it's true because the
toasters are always right that girl is
an amazing actress all the kids on the
society were relatively unknown except
for Katherine Newton she was in big
little eyes but they're still like
really up-and-coming and don't forget
she was in bad teacher oh how could we
they're amazing actors and actresses
like they're not like thirst monsters
they're just like really care about the
craft of acting yeah I follow Katherine
Newton on Instagram do you follow her
now you would absolutely love her she's
so plain II so pink she's like this cute
little white puppy dog she's always
posting pictures and glam
she's always quoting Elle Woods like
she's she's oh wow
oh my god it's so she doesn't give that
vibe as her character in society she
also have a good eyebrow day yesterday I
didn't check I don't think she posted
yesterday but I'll let you know we're
you shocked over my eyebrows well by the
way like I haven't been addressing them
I know it's been like the elephant in
the room
really we've to [ __ ] out them every
day not not since we've been like doing
a visual episode we only talked about on
the podcast oh my god you know I tend to
them last Friday and now I've been like
doing them darker and they're just have
like a different vibe to them I just
think your face is like different now
like it has dimension nothing you didn't
have dimension you get my close-up so I
everyone can see what we're talking it
has more dimension and I might when my
eyebrows were blonde I used to just have
to draw on a full eyebrow and now I feel
like I'm making my eyebrows the shape
that they were meant to be like I used
to be trying to make like a thick
Instagram brow I don't [ __ ] know yeah
and like everyone would call me Angry
Birds because I just made a straight
line across my face um but now they have
like this nice arched yes they are a
little thin a little 90s them even
though they're thin they're not know
you're made to your condition to think
that these are thin eyebrows because of
the age of Instagram eyebrows but these
are normal natural eyes just watching
mary-kate and Ashley movies and like
they didn't have Instagram eyebrows but
they had a great brow I mean a great
brow is everything and I feel like the
older you get even when you're really
set in your makeup ways you'll never
stop changing your eyebrows a because
trends change and be like it's hard to
find to get to a comfortable place yeah
and every day you have to do a new
eyebrow like you have to make your own
eyebrow it's crazy you know I'm getting
my eyebrows on tomorrow will say you
know and every day it's like sitting
with a haircut and I get my eyebrows on
the same day same place same person
every time
but it's always like you gotta hold your
breath I know everyone's probably
thinking like oh my god I look so
different cuz I got a haircut yesterday
and I'd really just honestly don't want
to talk about it
but your new co-host is a man it's
exciting though because I've always just
like it brings a different energy yeah
and we've needed some masculine energy
on the show we have and I'm thankful to
you for taking that plunge my hairy legs
and my short hair I'm really turning
into a man right before you Vanessa
Hudgens - Austin Badgers I refused to
drop the end that's fine and I wanted
what the branding you know idea behind
that was like it was such a cute Vanessa
and Hodgins I think it was going from
like Disney yeah it was a dad knee yeah
it was it was a maturity thing dat knee
Oh dizzy to detonate I refused to drop
the end I'm sorry that I hope she said
not like suffering you know must be hard
if we know that he's in Australia with
another girl like she probably knows
that as well
okay the helicopters today are really
out of confusing just like coming for us
all the time it's so frustrating being
the biggest star in the world it's just
you know this is the price you pay me
and Megan Marko both know like this is
the price when you're so famous it is
the price but obviously it's just such a
beautiful day I don't blame like these
helicopters for wanting to fly probably
some like nerd tourists like taking us
around the city with their feet out the
window oh god yeah
Zak once got us those I'm like something
for Valentine's Day and I was like never
in my life will I ever I've never been
then I said to him in an article a few
weeks ago that was like that company has
the most amount of crashes oh my god are
you're not gonna say the company um it
just seems mean get undertone it's fine
you know might want like a free plane
from them one day no I don't maybe we do
is it blade no no it's just one of those
touristy feet out there
oh I mean the people who put their feet
out of helicopter are so dumb nuts nuts
nuts nuts
okay next story really cool news Billy
Isla she's gonna perform the title song
for the James Bond film no time to die
love that there's been a lot of
speculation about who's gonna sing the
song because you know a dredge great
company Adele Tim Smith I seeing others
that we just don't know their name yeah
it was before our time but and I had
seen like some speculation that it might
be Beyonce cuz she posted a photo with a
martini but it's Billy Eilish and I love
this for her that is such an honor for
Billy Eilish I really am tik-tok has
really started to influence my taste in
music like that song dance monkey is my
favorite
it's such a great song and one of the
songs that kind of went viral on
tick-tock is ocean eyes by Billy Eilish
and now I'm just like such a stand I'm
such a stand because of carpool karaoke
we didn't ever talked about we did I
don't think that we did we talked about
it with each other oh but not on the
show
I don't think talk about everything on
the show we do but it was so good I have
so much respect for her I can't believe
she's only 17 let my bedroom into that
song himself all the songs sound the
same well we'll be getting another new
song called
I'm assuming no time to die from the
name it's gonna be called yeah I'm
actually really guy fall was Adele what
was his myths called bundini fine yeah I
believe it was Arella Bandini vibes yeah
that sounds right um this James Bond
film like I've never watched one but I'm
feeling like I might want to watch this
one because rami malek sent it I think
he plays a villain and I so love that
for him so villainy
he's so villainy I've seen and it's just
like Zak said on the show once you
weren't here in fact which is why he was
and he said any moving any superhero
movie is only as good as the villain
like if the villain isn't as strong
enough and I think that's what the
problem with Aquaman was because like
the villain turned out to be he's like
mom or something um if the villains on
Chong it's just like why are we fighting
so hard well that's why bring it on with
hayden Panettiere is such a good movie
because the villain Whitney she's an
amazing actress what ever happened to
that girl but that film is so good
because whinnies so evil yeah it's it's
really and it's like any season of The
Bachelor is only as good as the villain
so true like what do you think is the
villain this season I think well now
what they're doing is like there's no
outright like Olivia Creed evil and
we're like we hate people's lives right
exactly I think they're they're evolving
where it's like in each episode or two
episodes there's one mil and so I think
Hanna Anne will be a little villainous I
think the girl with the champagne kelsey
is villainy vibes it seems like Victoria
F is we just don't like her no no no
I've heard that she is
I don't know I can't believe we're only
two episodes into The Bachelor I know
feels like it's been on for a lifetime
and I still don't know anyone's name it
really is feeling like it's shaping up
to be a good season though really
because I thought that and I'm always so
negative about the bachelor and I've
been seeing a lot of people just being
like the girls are boring the season
sucks and people never say that I'm
always the one saying it really I think
the girls are cute they're they're cute
no but I think they're fun and I feel
like the ending is not gonna be your
traditional no Gary tail getting down on
one knee
I would agree what was the story we were
talking about feeling Eilish oh good for
her you know I hope she's making a lot
of money and I hope she's saving and
putting that [ __ ] in a 401k Oh first
sure hope she's surrounding herself with
people who really care about her and I
like Selina you know exactly Selina is a
tell is a what do they call it like a
warning story like a cautionary tale yes
so true do you have something else that
you want to say um that's a good
question you know I'm feeling like I'm
right you know yeah well we have like a
third story that's really fun and is
there someone who's sponsoring our third
story that's really fun Jackie that's so
funny that you asked that because I
literally just picked up my papers yes
and you're gonna die because the third
story is brought to you by cop ari my
favorite and they have any product which
is our new years number one resolution
is just to chill out and I've always
been pretty good at chilling out but I
feel like last year like I started to
like work and stuff and I got to chill
out because that's something it's easier
said than done but sometimes it's as
simple as taking a few moments to
yourself to soothe your body in mind and
one of our favorite ways to do that is
with the new CBD products from Kapaa
Reed you've definitely heard of
Campari's organic vegan premium grade
coconut oil products because we talk
about them all the time here on the
coast definitely heard of coke are is
something that might get your wrist snap
and it's the same attention to
ingredients that makes their CBD line
the one to trust it's hard to venture
into CBD you don't know like what's
what's real what's not and Campari is
such a reputable reputable brand that's
always putting like organic products and
safety first that I think that if you're
gonna venture into CBD claipari is
definitely the way to do it co parries
products use the only full-spectrum CBD
a whole plant powder on the market
combined with their famous coconut oil
and maximum absorption and ultimate
nourishment papaya is as dedicated to
sustainable and quality sourcing as
their CBD plants as they are with their
coconuts if you've got any aches kinks
in your muscles anything that needs
relief their CBD body balm cream and
recovery balm goes smooth
and feel amazing um so Ben's dad has a
bad back and actually gave him the bomb
and he's been loving and he's been
making Ben's mom put on his back every
night which she's not super happy with
me but I'm Sunday I was having really
bad cramps and my back was hurting or
they had Zack put it on my back because
I just gotten the new CBD cope hari and
it felt so much better like so so much
relief they have a cope re CBD deodorant
that can help soothe inflammation and
has the freshest or Bhatia's lavender
scent it's CBD it's not THC their
coconut CBD products won't get you high
they just soothe you and call me with
some of nature's biggest power players
paired to perfection and if you're going
to try a CBD product you should do it
right go with cope re if you've been
wanting to see what all the CBD hype is
about let this be the nudge you need you
can get 15% off all CBD products right
now when you go to cope re beauty.com
slash toast
that's cope re Beauty Co party spells KO
PA RI beauty.com slash toast for 15% off
your first order
the link is cope re beauty.com slash
toast you'll get 15% off your order
check it out check it out love it
sign on get cope re okay next story Kim
Kardashian denies booing Tristan
Thompson at basketball game the drama
okay so I avoided this story yesterday
because Kim and Connie were at the
Lakers game sitting next to Courtney Cox
did you see that of course I did and Jem
Eyre yeah jewelry and then people were
saying that she was booing Tristan and
now she's saying now I guess this where
I got big enough that she has to debunk
it okay but I just want to say what
happened on Twitter yesterday is
something you and I both predicted we
said on this show last week that
celebrities are now just like responding
directly to news articles about them
being like this [ __ ] isn't true and it's
always from Cosmopolitan Kim responded
cosmopolitan I literally stood up to
cheer for him yes to support him she
said I was there to support and support
him and was cheering screaming let's go
Tristan I would never go boo anyone I
don't go to hate only to cheer and it's
obvious that she's been watching share
on net leg who has she's inspired by
Jerry and his Matt talk and shares
positivity right and there she was on
the sidelines Matt talking Tristan
thousand percent I just think this whole
story is so frustrating first of all we
know Kim would she ever goat okay so it
was a Lakers game so she can go to any
Lakers game would she go to the one
Tristan is playing and he doesn't play
for Lakers he plays for Cavaliers so
would she go to the one that he's
just to boo him no she's not even
conversational when he the day after she
cheated on Chloe and she was in giving
birth she couldn't even say anything
Tim's right stuck her tongue out behind
him like she's not confrontational we
know that about Kim we know that about
Kim and Tristan does play for the King
Charles Cavaliers Bao's team and but
their husband's speculation that Chloe
interesting are getting back together
which is not something I brought to the
show because I do know that he is Chyna
and their relationship is China because
we're so done talking about it this is
our basket of people who have been China
and China means we no longer speak about
you because you were in the news so much
we've started to hate you I'm starting
to feel that way about Harry and Megan
but we're not there yet - Lee in the
term China if you're new here has been
named after black China because there
was a time in our lives like two years
ago when every day was something else
like Rob was posting pictures of her
vagina on Instagram now there was just
it was it became to be too much so we
China and her and that means we no
longer spoke about her and then we
included Tristan Thompson in the basket
because him and Chloe were becoming so
out of control every day was something
new the Jordan would stuff was like
salty and interesting but then I got to
a place where I was just so incredibly
over it right so we placed him in the
basket and then finally in the basket we
know he's a child Jacob Sartorius but
he's out of control on tick tock and he
beat me up for a People's Choice Award a
few years ago so we just don't talk
about him yeah but we were never really
talking about him to begin with so that
was like a pre-emptive China it was just
me being salty yeah it's like he could
get the roll of Elvis Presley and like
we still won't talk about him no I I
refuse to acknowledge his existence okay
I think that I think that's okay but
Tristan and Chloe like might be getting
back together who cares
for real like I am I care I don't care
about like I care about Chloe stop like
I'm okay and diehard Kardashian fan like
i will buy any product i will go to any
event like i love them so much i will
apologize for anything they do like i am
a blind stan but when it comes to chloe
interest in like whether they're
together or not i couldn't give a rat's
ass i gave a rat's ass about Chloe's
love life I'm also wearing good American
underwear right now because I got is
good should I show you it's so nice it's
like nice and tight is it coming for
skims
no it's a very different vibe because I
was putting on this dress today and I
was like I don't want to wear skin so
it's too tight and like this dress is
kind of loose but I need something to
hold on my [ __ ] together and my good
American panties came in and because I
got like a good American press package
which was just like so exciting humbling
joyous throw it in your mouth
it gave birth to it put it in a blender
and I just wanted to give a shout out to
the GA panties wait I went online less
yesterday there was a skims rootstock at
12 o'clock I got online at 12 before and
all the boob tape was sold out I just
want to try it my god I just want to try
it you should have seen me trying to use
[ __ ] shipping tape tibi like to get
at the TPG Awards yes it was painful it
took out my spray tan what did you do
did you end up using it no it didn't
need the skin State it's so anyway I
went on four minutes late I went I was
gonna get any shade because I wear it
under my dress so I don't care if it's
not my skin tone yeah all sold out damn
I'm sorry she should come out with clear
tape like that no it was terrible
no it won't be like shipping tape just
the same tape but clear but why I don't
know try it
but why like what is your purpose ahead
of development no but product about it
okay well just in case said it shows a
little bit it's not such a big deal I
guess like clear bra straps which no one
has ever used exactly okay are you ready
for an x-ray to tell us a bit of
Kardashian news and I found to be quite
into herself I'm always ready let me you
haven't talked about them in a few days
because we've been talking about the
Royals right but today's for the
American Royals it's a beautiful day in
America Kylie Jenner's assistant
Victoria the RAL quits to become an
influencer no I heard that that I read
this I'm like they don't know anything
where are you reading this from page six
movie it's not as salacious as it seems
it's like she was working for Kylie for
a few years and now she like quit
because she has 9 Ventura cam instagrams
she's just like being an influencer but
her and Kylie are still great and I feel
like it makes sense like for if they're
gonna be best friends it's weird if
she's hearses agreed and that's where
steps Shep I think got a little icky
when she was Kim's assistant she was
like going out with Kourtney and said
you're supposed to be working on kimochi
what are you doing get back to the
office like it just didn't make sense
and that definitely um happens I think I
do think it's a mistake when a lot of
the Kardashians like are always posting
and like promoting almost and their
assistants because inevitably they're
gonna grow beyond the role of being
someone's assistant like Chloe's
assistant who is a toaster she doesn't
really get posted she saw the show
sometimes but she is like maybe a
hundred K but I think it's just cuz
they're not best friends like no I
that way they may be learned and Kylie
are like the same age like they have the
same interest like it makes sense that
they would become friends but like Chloe
I think it just depends on me their age
I think they're also like learning not
to do that you don't even like theirs
they're phasing out of it like step shop
I think was a and they're still friendly
with chefs step shop but I think it was
like a big like learning lesson mostly
because stuff Shep not because she got
famous like I think the Kardashians are
always happy when their friends like
when they're like rising tides raise all
ships but it's because of that
refinery29 article where she just like
talked more about Kim than she should
have and like talked about doing the
laundry and working with like northen
everything that was weird
yeah and don't you think she should have
had to run that by Kim and like the
press team yeah and she didn't until I
think that was where it just got a key
but the fact that she was becoming like
a famous assistant I think Kim was fine
with okay no one's ever gonna be I guess
this whole thing came from Kim being a
famous assistant exactly no one's ever
gonna like I don't think Kim has to
worry about full-circle anyone eclipsing
her and I know they unlike especially
Kylie with her friends like she's always
posting them tagging and like I think
she's always now like with iris in her
lashline she's just like promoting their
businesses Stas in her bikini class
she's definitely a woman who supports
other women and I think the Ramona
Singer would be incredibly proud of the
woman Kylie Jenner is turning into yeah
and I'm happy that like she has close
friends around her and yeah I think
being her Kylie's friend for Victoria
was like more important than being her
assistant
yeah Victoria is literally one of the
most beautiful women like I follow her
on Instagram I like I'm in love with her
she's so beautiful I'm just so snatched
yes there's an final story a little
business oh my god his news we have had
business and so long the biz world has
been kind of quiet it has been kind of
quiet or maybe this lebra dog has just
been so loud well biz news is brought to
you by Felix gray if you constantly have
your face in a screen morning tonight
and I do my screen time is so
embarrassing that thing that they added
to the iPhone I wish it they wouldn't do
that I don't need to know how much time
I'm spending on Instagram a day it's
like three hours combined it's out of
control
um too much screen time can actually
result in tired dry eyes headaches
blurry vision and trouble sleeping I get
migraines from how much time I spend on
my phone and I also cannot say anything
like when I'm watching TV I have to put
on glasses now but not not since we've
been wearing Felix blue light glasses so
Felix grey I'm launching 2016 with the
singular focus to offer the most
effective computer glasses on the market
with all the quality of brand name
designer frames
quickly became the Internet's favorite
blue light glasses so they filter out
their glasses filter out 90% of
high-energy blue light and eliminate 99%
of the harsh glare coming from screens
so if your regular Felix gray glasses
before bed while you're scrolling your
phone for hours watching tik toks like
me when you take the glasses off you
won't have trouble falling asleep like
you normally would if you weren't
wearing glasses unlike other brands who
use cheap blue light coatings that are
ineffective and can chip or scratch
felix Square uses a proprietary blue
light technology that's embedded
directly into the lens they're available
in prescription non-prescription and
readers felix gray has you covered with
optical glasses for work and sleep
glasses in the evening that are
clinically proven proven to increase
melatonin secretion when worn leading up
to bedtime why would you buy glasses
from a company whose sole focus is it
making glasses we trust trust
Felix gray because they make the best
blue light glasses in the game go to
felix gray glasses comm slash Tosa and
get a pair of blue light glasses from
the pros shipping and returns are
totally free so go to felix gray fel ixg
ra y glasses dot-com slash toast
Felix gray glasses comm slash toast I
want to say sign on see well okay I
ready ready for some business that's
exciting from for some is the market
crushing for some aspiring for day work
week years like us oh my god I'm such a
big fan Shake Shack has rolled out a
four-day work week at dozens of
locations as the CEO says it's never
been harder to attract and retain
workers Shake Shack is using a four-day
work week to win over managers as
restaurant chains battle for employees
during a presentation here on Tuesday at
the ICR Conference Shake Shack CEO Randy
goo Rudy said the chain has rolled out a
four-day work week for managers as a
third of its locations it's never been
harder to attract retain and find high
quality employees he said according to
guru D the four-day work week has been
an incredible competitive advantage I
bet it is
in November guru D said on a call with
investors that the chain was looking to
expand the four-day work week to more
locations great maybe to some more
companies yeah I think the toast is
thinking about it the more toasters that
get four-day work weeks the more we can
move towards a four-day right because
like if everyone's working five days and
we're only working for them were
slacking people without contact when
they're mourning we are here to serve
your work we can to make your workday
experience more enjoyable as long as
that experience is five days a week
so are we damn I mean this is crazy I
feel like a lot of fast foods are like
making like company culture like so
premium like Starbucks they're paying
for your college it's up there always
like getting incentive that's Jaco Bell
also I guess had this big conference of
what does this fast food cumbersome why
was in are there yeah everything in
sight 100% it's the ICR conference and
it's what I see are Claudia needs to be
there conference yeah CNT BC I need to
go to see NTV same it's in Orlando which
is so of you know I love which is so you
know tacky like me Taco Bell recently
announced it would test a $100,000
salary for the general managers of
Symphony certain company owned locations
later this year
oh and Starbucks has been rolling out a
new mental health benefits for all
employees including a subscription to
the meditation app headspace Wow
Starbucks has been at the forefront of
this like they've been like leaning into
like providing different benefits for
their employees for a while and I think
that's really great I didn't know that
would make these fast food companies
we're having such a hard time retaining
employees who knew that was a problem
who knew cuz I thought it was like jobs
with a problem you know it's like no
jobs you know you are the problem well I
cannot believe that shake check is
having four days but that doesn't mean I
think their hours are changing that they
won't they'll be open more than four
days a week where employees yes exactly
that's so cool
you were pristine two jobs in one of
them was offering you a four-day
workweek check I just went to Shake
Shack when I was on my way home from
Atlantic City Miam and stopped at a rest
stop on our way home
it was 10:59 and the shake check closed
at 11:00 and I was the last person and
they littered the person behind me they
said they couldn't come in and these
people like wanted to kill me cuz me and
Ben obviously stood at the menu like for
three hours like should we get this for
that and it ended up getting a chocolate
milkshake and they've never had a
milkshake from Shake Shack before I mean
I'm just here to say I now know why they
named it Shake Shack this is some of the
best shakes I like the best chocolate
shake I've ever had in my life
Wow and it was just so simple nothing
crazy you like crazy fudge just like
plain chocolate I ate something I'm so
crazy to admit you've never had shake
shake I've never had shake shot it
doesn't surprise me
not even the fry I don't think because
you know why would I have a fry why
would I wait on that long line for a fry
yeah then I can just go to McDonald's
I've only had it a few times because the
line is so crazy and I've only had it in
airports they have two at JFK on and I
don't like live for the fries they're
the crinkly fries and I love crinkly
fries I like a straight skinny for
anything them
Nathan's not my favorite I would say my
favorite um McDonald's it actually might
be a tie I love Miami subscribe oh so
good and so different but Miami subs a
digital chain and it's more of like a
it's a potato yeah it's I think it's
only in Florida in Miami no because
we've been to one's not in Miami it's
only it's a Florida chain it's a
regional chain I don't think that all
the toasters know about it but it's
called Miami subs and it's so good and
they the best right there like seasoned
fries yeah they're so different really I
don't like that shit's a whole another
category yeah it's a whole other
category um you know what fries I don't
like is Burger King they're really
starting up Burger King Wendy's they are
on this like new healthy thing where
it's like they're real potatoes just
like salted you can hang you could see
like the little skin of potato to make
you think that is a real potato and it's
just like I'm not coming at Wendy's and
ordering fries to be healthy so just
give me the trans fats and go [ __ ]
yourself you know yeah that's how my
date would have wanted
not at all and definitely I'm sitting
next to Wendy herself so it's not what I
want remember when they did that casting
for like a new Wendy and they just like
looked for girls all over America and I
was right here and no one like called me
or anything I don't think I mean I don't
think they were just like knocking on
people's doors I think you should have
been like probably and it was also
before I had a good eyebrow day so why
would they have chosen yeah like Wendy
does have brows um we're gonna recap
banner from rules and then we'll dive
into deer toasters new episode of
Vanderpump rules last night nothing
really happened they're gearing up for
the wedding I can't believe the
wedding's only a month away and they're
not ending with the wedding it's in the
middle of the season yeah I think
there's so much more happening we know
that Stassi gets the edge later on
and so I I wanted to okay I don't even
know where to begin because was a weird
episode nothing really happened but we
moved the needle on how I feel about
people like Dana and her stand up oh my
god we have no choice but to stand up it
was watching someone do stand-up is
painful watching who someone who stand
up like on televised TV when like their
friends are there the guy like she had
me beat honestly she is so brave oh my
god I had land Allah tree home of the
brave
so much respect for her her jokes were
funny when she was like so many toxic
men in your life and you know my dad is
still around like it was so funny she
was the air pods and like when she that
is such a thing when it's like oh sorry
like I guess I came here yeah yeah no
she was very good I was surprised and
like just so the bravery knows no bounds
should you stand up anywhere is brave
but but to do stand up on a TV show you
just joined of all the guy you're seeing
is in the audience is the mid-level
drinker like
Maalik Kent is sitting there like sober
and remembering I think it's really nice
that Lala went and like it's really open
to the new girls and like the new people
because she was a new girl everyone was
so mean turn they made it so hard for
him like now I just seen her being best
friends with everyone and like I'm happy
for her for like being included but like
it just feels so I'm not like salty
about it it still bothers me the way
that they treated her and not only were
they not nice to the new girl but they
were so hard on her and it was only like
when she like came out with her
relationship it was like on pjs where
they all like turned around and it just
seems like like they like her now for
sure but the way they got there was so
not Jackie yeah it's like we can forgive
but we'll never forget never that's how
I feel and I love that Lala like isn't
turning her back on who she used to be
and she's embracing the new people and
like I want to know where her friendship
stands with Sheena because she it was
like one of the first people who like
she was really good friends with Lala
before all the girls like became best
friends with her and then like member at
someone's birthday party Sheena was
crying because they're all becoming
friends Lala and she knew that like Lala
was never gonna be her friend again and
they don't seem to be really friendly
okay as Sheena is like a whole other
topic that I just wanted just shelf for
one second
um I really did like that Lala reached
out to James he's not my favorite person
on the show and I know he sent a lot of
like terrible things but I think their
friendship what at one point was really
sweet no real yeah for a really long
time he was the only person that was
there for her and like I think they had
a lot of really good times um so I was
glad that they buried that hatchet and
I'm glad that she's now like in this
great place in her life friends with
everyone marrying a millionaire engaged
but she's not turning her back on the
people who got her there which was 100%
Jay right and so I'd like while I love
everything that's happened for her like
I'm really glad that she is still being
that girl that we know and love from
Salt Lake City okay I totally agree
totally um then Jax and Katie went over
to Kristen's house it seems like Katie
and Kristen made up at that Bachelorette
thing um and then they went over and Jax
was like kind of being helpful at mature
oh my god the best advice I've ever
heard and like very straight for I guess
like it takes a snake to know a snake
you know and like he saw the behavior
that maybe he would have pulled on
someone back in the day and I was just
so grateful that he was like having the
the backbone that Kristen needed Amba
Nations but she didn't have like the
wherewithal to you know keep like to be
consistent about yeah I really felt like
I was
feeling for Kristen in that episode
because not only is packing so
treacherous I could just tell she was
like sweating there was so much to do I
don't know why she didn't hire a mover
and then with all the Carter stuff and
everyone's like coming over her house to
yell at her like it was a lot and I
really felt for her yeah and also it's
like I understand now where she's coming
from a little bit more but it's like
she's broken up with Carter she feels as
though she's doing the right thing but
like Carter's gonna do and say anything
to get back in her good graces
not because he means it but because he
knows that's what she like needs and
wants to hear and she's only human right
and she's only humans to like when the
person that you're breaking up with is
telling you everything that you want to
hear but while living in your house
right so you don't know that it's just
cause like he has nefarious intentions
and has nowhere else to live it can be
very confusing of course she's confused
but it's seeing her yesterday on the
show just talk very straightforward it
seems like she's out of that dark place
yes and the logistics kind of cleared
themselves up and she's living in the
house alone and she's seeing other
people yeah and I will say like we
haven't seen a lot of her conversations
with Katie Stassi Lala but they have
been about Carter but that's because
they're bringing it up like when Stassi
said like we made a vow to never talk
about Carter again but we of course
broke it like if I had a friendship like
that and what I think I would try a lot
of different things but one of them
would be like okay you know what do
whatever you want we're not talking
about anymore like I just want to be
your friend for the reasons we became
from what's so frustrating and this is
when Lala was talking to Lisa Vanderpump
dogs she said like you know Kristen
keeps bringing it up and like we don't
want to be involved and it's like you
literally pulled Carter over at the
housewarming party to talk to him and
started the whole conversation yeah so
it's like and I get that they definitely
have to like have conversations
initiated in order for the show to like
move forward but everyone basically
taking the stand being like we want
nothing to do with this and then putting
themselves right in the middle of it
it's very hypocritical yeah so I just
want to see how things play out moving
forward we have we don't have enough
you're not getting a resolution you're
not getting arrested you're not getting
pulled over but don't have enough
information
I don't know how everyone's behaving yet
for me to make a judgment call but I'm
liking seeing where everyone is landing
right and they haven't been together yet
yes since um since that whole thing
Stassi was like not really in this
episode it's no there's so many people
now I think the cast is up to like 18
people that it's hard to get like a real
full episode of anyone like everyone is
really pulling their weight I actually
find the new people drama to be kind of
interesting especially how scheana
really okay now it's time to talk about
scheana to change her off the shelf I'm
taking scheana off the shelf and I'm
throwing her like in
because I'm so mad at her I'm so mad at
her behavior and it's just like Ariana
said you either die the victim or you
live long enough to become the villain
and that's exactly what Jean is doing in
the holdup because she's been through it
doesn't mean that that's how you treat
other people it should mean that you
know that you don't treat people you can
take a book out of law a page out of La
La's book Lala was the new girl everyone
was mean turn now law was the coolest
girl on the show and she's so nice to
the new girls scheana got bullied into
polishing the glasses then she you know
kind of came out and she's not another's
new people and she's doing the exact
same thing that Stassi and Katie and
Kristen say they're gonna bully someone
at least use your own tactics not some
ten-year-old ones and if you're gonna
bully someone like Billy someone who is
lame like Dana is so cool like she's so
she can't be bald and it cannot be bully
you also can't really you can't use your
job like untime on the clock to like
take out your personal vendetta against
someone and like she needs to be trained
and you're not training her like I need
Lisa to see this episode and like and
and she should've been working at Sur no
it's so [ __ ] up to use like your
workplace as a way to take out your own
grudges against people and the fact that
it all started with a boy is just so
crazy and like people I was watching
watch what happens live i was i mean
like SE Cupp was saying that like
scheana has just too big of a heart a
heart of gold because she got him an
Apple watch for Thanksgiving and it's
like that to me doesn't scream heart of
gold like but seems loser and I you
don't get someone a gift for
Thanksgiving by the way unless like you
in which case I've been missing out on
27 years of gifts yeah and I would like
to get for Thanksgiving yeah and I feel
like you get someone a gift like that
like to make them feel indebted to you
not like not out of the goodness of your
heart and it has like selfish
connotations because like you just want
them to be obsessed with you and you
want something in return
and also scheana keeps saying Maxon
there's such good friends like my best
friend my best friend meanwhile she goes
to dinner with the suspended manager and
the manager says one negative thing
about Mack said he's thirsty and she was
like yes hahaha no sheesh I know you
talked about your friend she's so
contradictory and it's like she loves
max but she also loves Brett and I like
love how Brett is just like not here for
any of it and it's just very
straightforward like we're friends like
that's it and yeah Mac when Brett was
like ending things with her before they
even began and then her interview cuts
to and I understand like interviews at
different times but she was like he
doesn't mean it you should have seen the
way he kissed me on the first date I'm
like yeah that's
didn't know you yeah no it totally she's
just she's out of control like wouldn't
Kristen said yesterday that she's like
the best scheana we've ever had maybe as
it relates to her friendship with girls
but as it relates to her relationships
with Liz it's out of control and I
usually wouldn't care like I I like a
girl like that who just like wears her
heart on their sleeve and is boy crazy
but when she's taking it out on other
girls who because it's just jealousy and
it's a girl that I now like who didn't
meet you up in front of while I can't
like I'm sorry but I'm just I'm not here
for it ya know girls who like who attack
other girls as it relates to men are
just so immature and it's like if
anything she should be mad at Max and be
bullying max no she's like obsessed with
max do you think max really told like
two random girls said he owned the bar
the way that he told the story made
complete sense agree me agreed I
actually really like him I like all the
new bad is how like a game of telephone
and miscommunication I saw like that
whole thing was summed up with a nice
bow on it like why those girls would say
like he owns the bar just cuz he said
it's my bar yeah and no one's really
wrong in that situation except for those
like they were just hugging so far so
far he seems like a nice guy that
suspended manager I did not like her she
was such like a [ __ ] stirrer she
couldn't believe she was gonna get to be
on the show so she came with all of her
notes and her legal pads and writing
down everything that she heard about
everyone on the show she was so thirsty
I really didn't like her no and I don't
I hope she's not gonna be come on him
the news cast members and I don't think
that I didn't think that she has I think
she just like was like I'm like a faith
like she just happened to be the right
time right place and had the right piece
of information yes
I think she's irrelevant I hope so my
god I really just liked her really
disliked her but I was glad that Ariana
was like sticking up for like just
saying that you know they were being
[ __ ] and she was just like no you
guys aren't aren't yes I really like
Ariana um except I don't know why she
went over to Lisa and asked for her job
back like what does she need to work at
Sur for well I think one liked the show
and I think she enjoyed it she was
really good at her job and then as she
like gelled him to her mental states and
she's moved into her house and like wow
she was talking about and they've been
talking about getting a house for so
long they lived in Kristen's old
apartments needed to save up for a house
so to get that and like have that
accomplishment and then like to realize
that you're still not happy like I feel
like it was so really great
relatable brave of her to share that and
I think that she misses that like
structure of of you know the mean
tasks working out sir I know but what I
really respected about her last season
was that she fully called Lisa out I'm
like making Tom and Tom look like idiots
when they were working really hard they
put up the money like they were just as
involved as she was and they just she
just like kept talking [ __ ] about them
like impressed and to other people and I
really respected Ariana I just mean with
her completely but then when Lisa said
and you know how I feel about Lea so and
she was like the greatest compliment I
could give them is to go into business
with them like that should be enough I
kind of hear you there's 18 people in
the cast and she chose the two of them
like I understand like she was annoying
and she held it over their heads and
blah blah blah but at the end of the day
like she chose she's giving them like
the opportunity of a lifetime for sure I
just I really respected how she like was
very straightforward and I didn't think
that she was talking a lot of [ __ ] about
least I think she was very direct and
went up turned I was like really I was
like damn that's brave yeah I don't
think Lisa was talking about that I feel
as though there were tweets and
interviews where ariana was calling out
Lisa for the way that she was treating
the Tom's well I respect that yeah and
what Lisa said when like someone's your
employee and they like want to talk bad
about the boss like you have to just sit
that was really self-aware very
self-aware and true but when someone's
not your employee like no now I can talk
to you straight we're just people mm-hmm
okay anything else wants a banner from
pearls before I wrap that up uh no I
feel I feel good about I was really
disappointed in scheana I just can't
stress that enough it's like it's been
eight seasons it's called growth baby
girl you should try it okay we're gonna
do our advice segment dear toasters
totally anonymous if you ever want to
write in email us dear toasters at
gmail.com we cover everything from work
stuff to wedding stuff to boyfriend
stuff your boyfriend anonymously donated
to a sperm bank we'll take care of it um
I haven't read these yet so let's dive
right in
and totally anonymous so don't worry and
this one comes with screenshots dears
teen Queens I have a story for you I
started dating a guy towards the end of
college we were both happened to also be
from the same area at home so we spent
the whole summer together as well when
we moved away for our jobs we visited
each other too one day he broke up with
me less than a week after I visited him
and we decided to give being exclusive a
try because I was just thinking about
Gina I feel like the last words that I
said we're like really hard growth this
big maybe girl like a [ __ ] how about
you condescending you're like Tiffany
power no I mean it's nothing of the
story because you're watching too many
Tiffany Valerie
we were watching TV powered videos
before we started the show so that's why
were both like a little salt it was just
somebody lied to her told her she was
spy and sexy she has nothing of the sort
no um Gina does need to grow up but that
was just harsh okay - I'm gonna start
again yeah yeah now I feel better going
into dear-dear esteem queens I have a
story for you I started dating a guy
towards the end of college we both
happen to be from the same area at home
so we spent the whole summer together as
well when we both moved away for our
jobs we visited each other - one day he
randomly broke up with me and this was
less less than a week after I visited
him and we decided to be exclusive there
was no bad blood we ran into each other
again a couple months later after not
talking and he ignored me at the bar I
left feeling really hurt the next day he
texted me for the first time in a month
and a group of 23 of my friends from
home saying he was sorry if I was upset
now I don't know if this was
accidentally done because he deleted my
messages from before or something but I
was like whatever it's cool I removed
him from the group and didn't think
twice the next week he texted the same
group that he had chlamydia and that I
should get tested so now I not only did
I know that he cheated on me since I got
tested during our time together but this
boy was out there pure dumb stupid or
trying to pull some power move on me I
didn't test positive but now I'm
terrified to go home because my friend
some people I'm less close with will
spread this around at home over break
how do I show my face and she said oh my
god she sends screenshots it says 20
people
he wrote hey sorry if I made you upset
on Saturday for some reason it was good
to see you even if it was only for a
second and then wrote whoops then like
the conversation like continues is
everyone going to Austin this weekend
and then a few days later he goes wanted
to let you know I tested positive for
chlamydia after getting an STD test I
would get tested if you test positive
then they give you a shot and then
you're completely fine most people don't
show symptoms so I don't know how long I
had it and everyone is like commenting
it's okay Jeff's like gotta love Eskimo
buddies so she wants to know do we think
that it was this was an intentional
thing and how does she show her face in
her hometown um okay this guy is like
such a piece of [ __ ] such a [ __ ] I
really don't think it was intentional
because that's too strange like I can't
even get on the mental level of someone
who would do that intentionally so I
just think maybe he doesn't know how to
use his phone and though I'm sorry I'm
so sorry like this is just it's too
weird to happen twice because people
responded to him the FIR
time so he was obviously getting these
texts I don't know I think maybe when he
typed her name in like sometimes when
you talked to someone more in a group
chat than you do in your one-on-one
chats the group chat comes up first yeah
but he realized the first time cuz he
sent it and then they said what no I
know but he probably did the same thing
again I don't think he went to that
group chat saw what he said last and
then continued like yeah real or maybe
he's hooked up with more than one girl
in that crew and it's just like sending
out a group text to everyone that he's
hooked up with and whose feelings he's
hurt I wouldn't be ashamed for you to go
home maybe everyone in the chat didn't
even know that that was for you and
second of all he should be embarrassed
he's the loser with chlamydia you didn't
even have it yeah I don't clean I'll
send like a really sharp salty text back
maybe with like a negative chlamydia
test photo just in case you're like
embarrassed about that put her under
snapchat give me other side of the group
chat be like I'm clean you're dirty dick
must have picked that up somewhere else
yeah with some other [ __ ] have a great
day honestly this is great for you good
for you for practicing safe sex I'm
really proud of you for coming out clean
and I think you're fine you have nothing
to be embarrassed about
this guy should be embarrassed one for
having chlamydia and two for not knowing
how to use a phone oh and also like even
if he gave it to you and like you want
to handle that personally and privately
that's fine and it really is just one
shot and so it's yes I had one idea but
I heard it's like the best one to have
and it also sounds like Claudia very
similar like good for you
okay that's good we just have a case of
the Claudia's yeah and by the way
everyone does I guess next up is titled
conflicted lesbian it's contagious hi
Claudia and Jackie so you two being
straight women may have trouble
answering this but you can probably
still help I have a close friend that
I've known for a few years and we bonded
from coming out to each other I'm a
lesbian and she is bisexual she's had a
boyfriend for a couple months but she
has never met him and it's long distance
though they are dating she constantly
flirts with me and holds hands with me
had a boyfriend for a couple of months
but and they never never met him he
they're a catfish like online
relationship okay yep okay that's just
like that's just standard she just
breathed right back even though they are
dating she constantly flirted me and
holds hands with me and even sits on me
in a sexual manner she also says that
she wants to marry me and raise kids
with me down the road I honestly really
like her a lot maybe even love but
obviously cannot to anything because
she's dating someone partially what do I
do about the fact that she is coming on
to me so hard love a conflicted Leslie
okay I thought that this was gonna be
like I don't know if I'm a lesbian and I
honestly don't feel like I'm like ready
to give advice like that so I'm glad
that you know you're a lesbian I'm
really happy for you right this girl
sounds like honestly she sounds like
trouble yes well not to be like so
judgmental but like people who start
online relationships with people they've
never met like it's weird and I know
there's there's you know something for
everyone but this is [ __ ] it
sometimes it's a success and you know
bah bah bah but a lot of times like it's
me children weird and honestly it seems
like to me like your friend is a bit of
like she just loves the attention like
she doesn't have her online boyfriend
she wants like you to be in love with
her and just like wants it from
everywhere and I think I think you
should say something to her I know it's
like it's not even funny now cuz like a
real feelings I think you should say
something to her but like I never would
you know of course not but this show
this segment is just like me giving
advice to people if [ __ ] I would never
do like that I would like run away and
never talk to anyone know if this was me
I just like shove her off my lap and
just like pretend like it wasn't
happening until like something came to a
head no I wouldn't maybe until she broke
up with honestly I'm so patient and if
you're in love with her back
I would like wait until this
relationship inevitably fizzles out
maybe like you know send him some like
like text me to make sure their
relationship ends and then be like
waiting in the wings ready to like heal
her heart I'm curious if she's only
started coming on to you
sounds like you've known her for a while
she's only coming on to you since having
a boyfriend because then that's annoying
but if she's always been this way like
maybe you guys have always had something
yeah and like maybe that's just who she
is and no offense you're not special
so did we land somewhere on giving this
girl advice my advice like what I would
do if I were in the situation which
isn't the best advice to give but given
my personality type and I am very
patient I would wait for the
relationship to end maybe I would do
something to like push it towards its
end you know what I would do I just [ __ ]
her you know like it sit on my boyfriend
he couldn't even not exist like how do
we know he's real it could be a robot it
could be Siri like you never know that's
a good [ __ ] just like know when she's
sitting on your lap flirting like wow I
like let's see where it goes spread
those legs yeah I just said go for it
[ __ ] I think that's really good advice
oh it's great advice thing you don't
know this guy neither does she
why don't you oh this like a mythical
creature he could not even exist what do
you owe this IP address totally okay our
final one is titled
I'm the family [ __ ] dear Claudia and
Jackie I
come from a sort of conservative family
and I've definitely dated and brought
more guys around my extended family than
any of my cousins have I have no
siblings
our big family Christmases have always
included aunts uncles cousins
grandparents super random people who
don't have anywhere to go so many years
I would bring a little pack of friends
including some dudes I've been dating
around for like 12 years and I've
probably bought five guys over two
holidays or as wedding dates either
because there's nowhere else for them to
go like in college when they couldn't go
home for the holidays or because we were
seriously dating five guys over 12 years
is not bad crazy also like good for you
for like bringing guys home who have
nowhere else to live like are you
running a homeless shelter but you said
that very casually like I would bring
people home in college when they had no
home
I've almost got married once or twice
engaged once before but he cheated about
to get engaged my amazing current
boyfriend who is rad and will be my
husband for sure basically I probably
ran my mouth too much in my earlier
years of dating about marriage because
my family kind of frowns on dating
unless it's leading to marriage I'm
basically the family [ __ ] now and some
of my idiot alcoholic family members
make fun of me make fun of me for always
bringing around some guy I know I could
have avoided this by being more discreet
but I think that I should get to do
whatever the [ __ ] I want and they should
all [ __ ] off I honestly want to elope
because all the [ __ ] I've gotten through
the years these people don't deserve to
attend a wedding what can I say what can
I say that these people to show them
that dating is normal and my choice and
not something I must do because I
couldn't lock down some dude which I
always could have Jesus Christ what can
I say to make them feel like idiots for
the double standards they have with me
as a girl whereas my uncle who used to
date a lot was teased in a more or less
in a more painful playful less intensely
critical way I know that you probably
have more interesting mail to respond to
on air but I think this is something a
lot of ladies from conservative families
face and I want there to be a solution
that doesn't involve showing up alone to
a holiday party to hide my dating life
which would then lead to all other
questions of are you dating will you
marry
xoxo the family [ __ ] that's tough I
never really thought about that just
because um like I only brought home one
person and like yeah it was it but I
don't consider like dating to make you
[ __ ] like all right if you're bringing
home a different man every night then I
think you know we have something to talk
about but five guys over 12 Christmas is
like sounds like you've a really healthy
and mature dating life yeah I don't know
I like if it were me and I were in this
situation I would just kind of tune out
their opinions you know especially if
it's like your cousins aunts and uncles
like you see them a couple of times
you're like you can handle it then but
so her concern is that when she brings
home her eventual fiance that they're
gonna like this she just she wants to
elope she doesn't want these types of
people at her wedding and she doesn't
know how to he have a fiance no but
she's engaged and she like she's married
and she's dating this guy and she like
knows that he's the one like they're
gonna go okay so bring him of course
yeah but no she doesn't want them and at
her wedding she wants to real oh then
you should for sure elope bring him to
Christmas live your life do what you
want [ __ ] those people it's like but it
when it concerns their opinions that
like really don't involve them like you
should respect your family and bla bla
bla but like this is absolutely nothing
to do with them so they just want to
have their [ __ ] opinion that's fine
and then after Christmas like you get to
go home with the love of your life how
wonderful this is though like the
age-old dilemma one in which I
definitely face like being the person
who cares so much about what other
people think but also mean like I don't
care what anyone thinks about me even
though I'm like crippled with self-doubt
so it's so much easier said than done to
like [ __ ] what everyone thinks about me
but I'm sure she does want to change the
opinion I'm like people her family like
I think the opinion will change when
every Christmas it's the same guy that
she's bringing home and then that like
she had to kiss five frogs right I was
crazy to find the right guy for her you
know I think once she's like married and
settle down and doing what they deem is
what she should appropriate then like
the past is just the past the past is
the past thank you for writing in you
guys make sure to email us to your
toasters at gmail.com we always keep it
anonymous you can write it about
anything weird crazy normal we will get
it on air so check it out toasters at
gmail.com and that is our show for you
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning toast the Millennial morning
show where we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to give this
video a thumbs up subscribe you know
what to do get the little Bell thing you
know just hit it up
we're also that also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
at spotify itunes stitcher public video
i our videocast box all the places so
wherever you choose to listen to
podcasts subscribe to us and leave a
five star review but have beautiful
stunning it's where we are we love you
guys so much we will see you tomorrow
for our final live show our final show
of the week tomorrow right and when
you're going early tomorrow 9:30 a.m.
because we got flights to catch because
we catch flights not feelings so 9:30
a.m. is our last show of the week
tomorrow make sure to check it out tune
in live if you usually listen to us a
podcast head over to youtube.com slash
morning toast have an amazing day
everyone we'll see you tomorrow bye bye